[Musique]
à
c'est
dit
j'appelle ça ne fait rien bienvenue dans
votre taux du samedi soir bonsoir
avec vous ce soit pointé rien de choix
et un robot gens me
l'ont clamé zimmer avec jean mi ce soir
josiane balasko
josiane balasko bonsoir alors je viens
ici ce soir pour nous parler de votre
nouvelle pièce et aussi parce que le 31
mars france 3 vous consacre une soirée
entière d'abord avec un téléfilm la loi
de barbara puis le divan de marc olivier
fogiel ça sent le sapin quand même non
j'allais j'ai déjà eu un césar d'honneur
ya quelques années je suis toujours à
quoi et en même temps
[Applaudissements]
lago de feu
la 29e bonsoir vous êtes un rappeuse
dont tout le monde pas la seule
révélation du rap féminin depuis diam's
c'est à dire que vous aussi vous êtes
capable de mettre des talents au avec un
survêtement non je m'égare pas dans ses
thématiques et michel onfray
jambes amont soit très heureux de vous
revoir vous savez que vous êtes devenu
mon invité préféré un peu comme guy
bedos pour michel drucker ou marine le
pen pour jean jacques bourdin
[Applaudissements]
en plus de 3 après le zapping et gaspard
proust nous accueillerons nos terriens
du samedi 20 heures ce soir gilles et
marcel nuss qui est paul vi handicapée
elle était assistante sexuelle ils sont
tombés amoureux fous et ils se sont
mariés incroyable histoire voilà
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le robot s'appelle jour me et le groupe
les gréement de fortune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
josiane balasko re bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
or josiane
josiane josiane j'adore ce prénom en
fait votre mère n'avait pas d'idée de
prénom et c'est là que votre frère va la
piscine et qui rencontre une fille qui
s'appelle josiane à vue à la piscine du
fis qui devait être canon et la dior
josiane bon voilà c'est un prénom de
pauvres josiah main
ensuite vous avez prouvé courageusement
qu'on peut devenir une star de cinéma ça
plonge au diable et aujourd'hui c'est la
fierté de tout les josiane et josiane de
france sont fiers de vous et vous êtes
la josiane la plus célèbre du monde à
josiane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il paraît que quand vous étiez petit
vous détestiez votre prénom car ça
faisait pauvres et que vous vous faisiez
appelé clémentine c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai mais pas longtemps se dire quand je
suis allé au cours de théâtre je m'étais
fait faire une carte et j'avais dit aux
clémentines ce qui est du reste et
personne ne m'a jamais appelé que les
montées dans cet exploit d'avoir fait
une carrière avec un prénom pareil a été
célébré par un césar d'honneur au dit qu
césar nouveauté un peu par hasard
souvent pour des potes et que tout le
monde fait ça c'est bidon ce truc là en
fait non c'est pas bidon non bah oui
puisqu'ils font tout le monde fait ça
mais finalement il ya des gagnants ouais
enfin les gagnants sont pas les
meilleurs noms des gens que je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui doivent voter très
sérieusement alors césar d'honneur
soirée hommage sur france 3 vous avez vu
vous dernière analyse ne sont là ça non
c'est très sympa d'avoir une émission
moi je pense qu'ils auraient dû les bons
faut pas gaver donc le plus belge que je
n'aime pas ce jour là ça va
et puis le théâtre alors vous concourrez
pour un molière d'honneur
j'ai ainsi avec un grand moment de
solitude à partir du 7 avril prochain la
michodière ans est un type plutôt
déprimant enfin moins déprimant que
regarde en haut je viens de me pendre
non mais ça arrive quand même
un petit peu déprimant pas le contenu
non aux marrons oui mais j'espère alors
c'est écrit mis en scène et interprété
par vous on peut venir voir la pièce
vous faites aussi le public
non il ya des gentils viennent aussi
curieux que ça pue ça marche bien
alors le pic c'est l'histoire de deux
petits il y en a un qui est agoraphobe
l'autre qui est une accumulatrices
compulsive et c'est elle qui va profiter
du psy agoraphobe qui sort pas de chez
lui évidemment aux planques et son mari
chez lui c'est ça oui c'est ça son mari
qui est un disons un lanceur dallaire
jean snowden qui est recherchée par tous
pratiquement toutes les polices et qui
va se lâcher c'est lui et l'autre ne
peut même pas appeler les fixes il
appelle les fruits qu'ils vont venir et
peut être entendu à se déplacer
peut-être il sera mis en examen donc il
est coincé alors le rôle du lanceur d'
alerte est tenu par votre mari george
aguilar il va bien chez belfond but il
va très bien il à travers que j'hésitais
malescot émergé avec un chef indien oui
c'est vrai ça veut dire qu'il est pauvre
et alcoolique et qui vit dans une
réserve et non non non et les indiens et
là on leur a décrit taux de suicide le
plus fort aux états unis et qui sont
aussi d'obésité parce que vu la
nourriture et d'alcoolisme bien sûr
puisque les colons leur ont gentiment
c'est connaître le vin comment ça se
passe la vie quotidienne avec un indien
c'est vrai qu'ils laissent des plumes
parts c'est super cool normalement ya
faute il a pas de portable il envoie des
signaux de fumée mais vous avez et j'ai
blagues éculées j'adore
alors votre fille était pas libre 1
c'est dommage sinon il aurait joué dans
la pièce en revanche votre chien vous
l'avez trouvé un rôle ouais j'aime bien
le chien au bas parfois mieux que nous
alors on n'a pas trop le droit de parler
politique ce soir à cause des
départements tels mais on peut dire deux
mots de françois hollande
vous qui êtes tellement concernés par le
problème du droit au logement
vous savez que françois hollande risque
d'être expulsée dans deux ans
ouais alors j'ai le souvenir en 2017 ou
bien on a bien ri ça suffit comme ça moi
je crois que j'ai fait officiellement
plus soutenir personne oui alors dans le
grand journal vous l'avait apostrophé
françois hollande en lui disant réveille
toi mon gars c'est exactement ce que lui
dit julie gayet tous les soirs où ça
et on passe maintenant à notre tékitoi
de la semaine
[Musique]
jaloux de feu rebond soir vous êtes donc
un peu dans tout le monde pas celle qui
montre que dans le rap les filles
peuvent faire autre chose que se
trémousser en string au bord d'une
piscine
c'est vrai alors vous dites depuis
diam's personne n'a fait de hic il y à
un vide dans le marché diam's s'est
barré elle a laissé son sac de sport et
personne ne l'a ramassée sauve ou en
fait la personne qui est venue en fait
c'est bon c'est vrai et maintenant il ya
tous ces mecs ou ultra testo et
vacheries sur la faune sont dedans et
tout mais il n'y a pas de femmes les
personnes parlent aux femmes et
personnes parlent aux mecs qui ont des
femmes dans leur vie fin voilà donc je
suis là alors pour écouter ce que vous
faites on peut télécharger gratuitement
votre nouvelle hippie lago la cuisse le
beef et si on veut en savoir plus il
faut regarder salut les terriens
insight je tiens à ce qu'ils aillent
beach
une [ __ ] je serais déjà dedans tâche
n'est beach fut moi je te suis moi je te
fuis au final qui suce qui j'ai pas la
tête de l'emploi mais ils ont tous la
même une ganache pâte balaj pad calage à
paname faire tâche celle summum bonhomme
les hommes d'aujourd'hui sans l'état spe
d'hier je venais pas en lui je traite
chose à faire ban en liquide faut que je
m'arrache du cir
[Musique]
j'ai pas fai métier et moi lago de feu
ça s'appelle monstre un
super flow un fond d'eau n'est pas
vraiment ça vous michel bonne énergie
avoue josiane ah oui j'aime bien vite
fait de la scène alors oui j'adore
c'était le but en fait parce que je me
cache en fait j'ai peu dans mes clips je
me montre jamais et c'est sur scène que
je suis habité posséder ouais c'est très
très impressionnant
alors des paroles très réaliste vous dit
arrêtez de vous inventer des vies
pourquoi tu veux mettre une lamborghini
dans ton clip alors que chez toi t'as
même pas de sauce pourtant on rit
c'est la vérité aujourd'hui c'est l'ère
de tous sur soi rien chez soi mois est
chez moi c'est mon univers gg tout et
puis quand je fais dehors je m'en fout
en fait je suis armée parce que j'ai ma
vie j'ai mon ailleurs en fait alors il
ya des phrases incroyable j'ai une
devise j'accepte toutes les devises que
je trouve génial je suis un mec sans
toit des couilles
et je vais pas te sucer pour le succès
j'aime toutes ses phrases c'est
vachement bien s'annoncer annonce la
couleur ces annonces à ces écoliers ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu
aujourd'hui sur le féminisme c'est les
féministes ca les chiennes de garde tout
le monde en colère et tout mais tu as le
droit d'être une femme ne respectez les
hommes d'avoir besoin des hommes mais de
reconnaître qu'on a un peu exploités
dans le monde du travail et que c'est
compliqué de faire sa place
un nouveau féminin
allait bien alors dans vos clips sur
internet on vous voit pas pourquoi parce
que vous êtes blanche pas du tout
j'aurais été un mec black j'aurais quand
même rappeler celle annoncée en moins il
fallait que je m'exprime ou alors vous
avez peur qu'on découvre que vous êtes
une petite bourges du 6e non parce que
justement j'ai jamais j'ai grandi dans
le 6e ça m'a pas empêché d'être curieuse
et d'aller vers l'extérieur le problème
des quartiers quel qu'il soit c'est
quand et pas curieux et que tu restera
enfermé sur tes trucs et des codes moi
je suis une nomade donc je me promène
partout et voilà c'est pas votre mère
qui vous a demandé de prendre un pseudo
annoncé - en fait c'est moi la maire de
la gaude de feu pourquoi lago de feu ça
veut dire quoi alors lago ça veut dire
la fille et de feu parce que je suis
claire nom de feu la gourou quoi lago en
fait c'est en fait c'est le sling
ivoiriens en fait d'un accord a
bigrement il s'appelle comme ça les fils
et dans l'argot ivoirien fille de feu
fils de feu lago de l'est en fait
mathieu gens réagissent très célèbres
dont je ne citerai pas de noms parce que
vous ne souhaitez pas qu'on le fasse si
on avait dit qu en plus mon parle pas
d'elle c'est formidable
[Rires]
évacué vers des mots
c'est pas parce que vous aimez pas votre
corps que vous vous montrez pas dans vos
clips non c'est pour que justement on
ait envie de voir comment je suis en
live en fait en vain parce qu'on se dit
tu vois une grande blanche comme ça tu
dit elle c'est faux on me demande
toujours c'est toi qui écris tes textes
et aux verts bref quand on voit ces
terribles et puis suis trompé je vis le
truc quoi mais j'aimerai quand vous
étiez petit vous étiez un petit peu un
un garçon manqué où il y avait un garçon
mais je rêvais d'aller faire pipi debout
et le service militaire vous dites quand
j'ai mis du temps à m'habituer à mon
corps de femme ouais beaucoup de temps
pourquoi parce que ça c'est un truc dont
tu peux te servir pour avoir du pouvoir
sur les autres c'est pas ce qui
m'intéresse moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la puissance le rayonnement me sentir
bien et en fait je mets du temps quand
tu es une femme de fou à reconnaître que
tu es une femme et que ben il ya tout un
truc qui va avec qu'il faut apprendre à
s'en servir quoi votre drogue ces deux
sports en fait oui j'entraîne une équipe
qui s'appelle boost odéon je les
entraîne toutes les semaines j'ai aussi
mon gang de go que j'entraîne tout le
temps qu'ils sont un grand jeu court
j'ai fait de la boxe je fais du
renforcement musculaire chez tous et
vous dites quand vous courrez ont fait a
fait la cuisse alors la cuisse c'est la
vie ouais parce que on est aussi dans
une ère où il faut avoir la cuisse
creuse sa femme et c'est pas ça c'est ça
le truc le cheminement pour apprendre à
pasqua qui tu es en fait quelques mois
peut-être que celle ça lui convient mais
ça convient pas forcément à tout le
monde alors faites vous êtes un mix
entre booba et véronique et davina
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était la peur de citer on se
retrouve sur terre après la pluie a tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir l'intérieur rebond soir les
terriens nous sommes de retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de josiane balasko
de la bonne feu les musiciens l'ont fait
et de jean nuit
et maintenant mesdames messieurs nous
allons entamer cette deuxième partie
avec un blind test philosophie donc à
chaque chanson michel roux frais va nous
expliquer la morale de la chanson voilà
attention blindtest philosophie
[Musique]
on se concentre attention didier
et
pas
michel onfray le travail est-il
libération ou une aliénation
on va pas répondre dans l'absolu ça
dépend pour qui quand le travail c'est
une passion c'est probablement la santé
on peut pas arrêter d'ailleurs de
peindre d'écrire c'est pas la même chose
que de faire un boulot qui détruit la
santé et qui obligea prostituées son
corps le travail n'est pas
obligatoirement la santé voilà très bien
voilà c'est très bien voilà une halte
est très instructive vous remarquerez
attention didier
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
you can't always get what you want on ne
peut pas toujours obtenir ce que l'on
veut michel onfray faut-il rechercher ou
non la satisfaction de tous ses désirs
il ya une époque où on disait oui
systématiquement way tous les désirs
sont bons mais quand même les désirs qui
sont destructeurs d'autrui mais ça dit
que ça existe un masochiste est pas
grave s'il se fait du mal ce qui va de
soi même mais non tous les désirs ne
sont évidemment pas bon c'est comme avec
le travail peut faire
attention bravo parfait attention didier
mais si près
[Musique]
il
m
alors nukem torride on ne peut pas
brusquer l'amour michel onfray la
libération sexuelle at elle tué le
charme de la cristallisation stand
aliens
la cristallisation c'est un rameau qu'on
a plongé dans les mines de sel à
salzbourg et vous êtes aperçu que les
cristaux se constituer comme ça autour
du rabot et stendhal dit que l'amour
c'est ça une cristallisation oui quand
ça va trop vite évidemment il n'y a pas
le temps de cristalliser on doit dans le
temps de d'apprendre d'amour c'est
d'abord une construction s'est pas donné
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui tombe du
ciel comme ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut aussi désiré vouloir fabriquer
construire ça prend trop le temps de la
gale la cristallisation et ben voilà les
chiffres m ce en raison i can't hurry
love didier
[Musique]
je ne sais pas moi je
non anne a rejeté
je sais pas born to be wild steppenwolf
à mener pour être sauvage josiane
l'homme n'est-il bons est-il rendu
mauvais par la société
ça je crois que c'est une idée
extrêmement dangereuse était celle de
rousseau ouais mais on a oublié que
quand rousseau dit ça existe une
hypothèse et quand robespierre dit ça
n'est pas une hypothèse c'est une vérité
il estime qu' effectivement il suffit de
changer la société en coupant quelques
têtes pourquoi obtiennent un homme bon
on a vu ce que ça a donné par la suite
avec la révolution française puis la
révolution russe puis la mine etc non il
ya une nature humaine et la sai on en
est des animaux darwin et ah bon c'est
même pas un ni deux ni bons ni méchants
enfin j'veux dire que quand darwin écrit
je sais pas l'origine des espèces il
nous montre que les animaux ils sont
dans une logique de défense du
territoire donc on est resté ces animaux
là attention didier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
michael jackson don't stop til you get
enough ne t'arrête pas tant que tu n'en
as pas assez alors faut-il tout obtenir
ne serait-ce que pour pouvoir tout
méprisé michel onfray n'ont sûrement pas
tout obtenir je pense que le désir chez
aussi partie de ce qui rend possible une
existence tendre vers quelque chose
regardez les gens qui n'ont pas grand
chose qui jouent au loto qui ont tout
d'un seul coup un comment souvent ils
obtiennent de désespoir en même temps la
vraie richesse et de désir est en deçà
de ce qu'on a là on est roi du monde
vous êtes sages c'est bien ça le fait
toutes les attentions didier
je ne sais pas si désolée je sais pas
mais c'est un truc qui me dit que tu
changes
chagrin d'amour
[Musique]
oui
michel onfray chacun fait ce qui lui
plaît plaît plaît chagrin d'amour la
liberté des uns s'arrête tél où commence
celle des autres est souvent une erreur
sur le sur le mot liberté on a
l'impression que c'est le pouvoir de
faire ce qu'on veut quand on veut comme
on veut avec qui on veut et c'est
souvent contre qui on voudrait aussi et
ça c'est la licence c'est pas vraiment
la liberté la liberté ça se construit
[Applaudissements]
attention didier
[Musique]
un bravo
un item passe passe passe le oinj la
drogue peut elle avoir des effets
positifs sur l'activité intellectuelle
michel onfray jamais remarqué que ça
rendait plus intelligente ce qu'il
n'était pas ouais je pense
qu'éventuellement quand il s'agit de
baudelaire avec le haschich quand il
s'agit d'un automate coincé avec quincy
avec eux
l'opium on peut imaginer que quand déjà
on a un grand imaginaire la drogue peut
aider à développer cet imaginaire si on
est con ça voulait ce constat peu ta
conclusion je pense ça sera la
conclusion
[Musique]
michel onfray re bonsoir
alors la semaine dernière j'ai fait la
une du magazine le point avec ce titre
le philosophe qui secoue la france
il ne lui manque plus qu'une relation
avec françois hollande pour faire la une
de closer
le problème c'est que françois hollande
quand il fait des dîners avait visé il
n'invite pas michel onfray non il
préfère inviter marion cotillard yannick
noah ou joey starr c'est décevant quand
même qui se ressemble s'assemble
[Applaudissements]
alors la lune du point c'était à
l'occasion de la sortie de votre nouveau
livre cosmos publié chez flammarion
alors l'oubli du cosmos dit vous me
paraît l'un des signes du nihilisme
contemporain
nihilisme c'est l'absence de valeurs
c'est le fait qu'on n'ait plus de
boussole conçoit paumé complètement et
je pense effectivement que les gamins
dans les banlieues qui ne connaissent
que le béton le bitume les caves la
lumière artificielle qui ignore la
nature les cycles de la nature ce que la
nature nous enseigne les rivières les
poissons enfin les paysages les
montagnes la vastitude des paysages
quand on ne sait pas ça manque quelque
chose d'essentiel pour se construire se
constituer alors tiana qui vivaient dans
le cosmos et votre père gaston offrait
le livre commence par une préface vous
évoquez sa mort dans vos bras vous aviez
tellement redouté qu'il meure en fait
pendant une de vos absences parce que
vous faites de nombreux déplacements
oui oui c'est surtout les longs
déplacements quand je fais des
conférences au japon en australie en
inde ou en amérique du sud on se dit si
quelque chose arrive faut que je
reprenne un avion j'ai toujours eu peur
de ça et il se fait que m'a fait ce
bonheur de mourir entre
en fait dans mes bras alors qu'on
regardait le ciel tous les deux déjà dit
ce qu'il avait appris les étoiles et il
avait besoin de se boucher je le
conduisais de ma petite maison dans mon
village natal à la sienne et sur la
place du village il a fait mouche et
j'ai regardé le ciel le ciel était
couvert jeudi enverra pas dans ses
toiles ce soir et m'a dit non ce soir le
ciel est couvert il est mort debout
comme un coma chênes qu'on abat pas
parce qu'il est resté debout mort debout
en regard de son frère il y avait des
chevaux des cadavres des hommes des
chariots tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
dans quand j'ai une armée quoi y'a que
les gens qui étaient dans l'art
dans le manoir qui sont trouvés qu'ont
vécu tout ça la bataille quoi ils ont
été dix jours sans pouvoir sortir là
les manoirs chez madame der mignon oui
mais dans une cave quand c'était un obus
allemands j'ai dressé la tête quand
c'est un double mérite qu'un seul à
baisser
mais reconnaissez ben c'est à dire les
américains nous faisait et les autres
partis bah oui sens contraire
parce qu'on a peur de la mort dans ces
cas là comment ça se
met
pratiquement je te pour dire que j'avais
peur de la mort comment
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous dites en vendant votre père pour
lui les mots avaient un sens les paroles
données valeur de serment et les choses
dit force de loi vous êtes bien son fils
alors votre père n'avait jamais pris de
vacances à l'été ils allaient travailler
dans les fermes voisines pendant ses
vacances il ya un endroit où il voulait
aller c'est le pôle nord et vous l'avait
emmené au pôle nord ça a été les seules
vacances de sa vie en fait un jour mon
planter des patates tous les deux il y
avait un avion qui passait jeudi j'avais
8 ans si tu devais aller un jour quelque
part c'est un billet d'avion gratuits ce
que tu es quand même très improbable où
irait tu en perds qui n'avait aucun
désir aucune envie qui était pourquoi je
sais ce qu'est la véritable richesse des
gens qui ne désirent pas et qui ont le
monde il me dit au pôle nord donc je
garde ça dans ma tête et un jour je lui
dis tu vas avoir 80 ans si tu veux je
t'emmène au pôle nord évidemment on est
arrivés sur place et pas le pôle nord
qu'il avait imaginé un peu déçu par la
modernité bien sûr on en est où le
massacre de la planète
on était au mois d'août le lait neige
avait fondu la glace aussi et les
quelques iceberg un peu plus loin il a
sympathisé avec un vieux chamane et tous
les deux évidemment mon père ne parlait
pas l'hymne aux petits tout le chaman
non plus nous parlait pas français mais
il y avait des gens qui parlaient
l'anglais on traduisait en paix et ils
ont tous les deux sympathisé parce
qu'ils étaient du même monde des chamans
des paysans des vieux sages des gens qui
effectivement ça fait prendre leur place
dans la planète
[Applaudissements]
alors si le point vous appelle le
philosophe qui secoue la france c'est
que vos propos portent
ce que vous regrettez un peu quand même
c'est que vos tweets porte sur plus que
vos livres oui c'est un peu terrible
c'est à dire j'ai créé une université
populaire j'ai démissionné d'éducation
nationale justement pour lutter contre
le pen au deuxième tour en 2002 ça fait
13 ans que j'enseigne gratuitement
bénévolement à l'université populaire et
je fais un tweet en dix ans ici à
l'école on apprenait à lire à écrire à
compter plutôt que la théorie du genre
immédiatement dans libé dans le monde
coming out réactionnaire de michel
onfray alors que je me contente de dire
des choses extrêmement bas n'a cédé à
penser tweetos quoi pour vous oui alors
c'est la vie schiste pétainiste fasciste
atteint l'asie c'est dommage parce que
ces mots-là signifie quelque chose et
quand on veut vraiment les utiliser par
exemple antisémite ça veut vraiment dire
quelque chose mais quand on les utilise
à tort et à travers ça devient dangereux
parce que comment on peut vraiment
lutter contre le véritable antisémites
et savoir là où il est alors dire que
quand même vous haïssez la gauche caviar
vous dites cette gauche tellement
libérale qu'elle défend la vente
d'enfants en justifiant la location
d'utérus des femmes pauvres pour des
couples riche la gauche de pierre bergé
qui estime que louer son ventre c'est la
même chose que travailler comme
caissière il ya effectivement un certain
nombre de l'idée qu'ils font qui font
honte à la gauche et il se fait que
cette gauche dans audi ce genre de
choses mais moi je vois plein de gens
qui me disent heureusement vous dites
des choses comme ça parce que nous on
pourrait ici on n'ose pas une des
raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes accusé
de dérive droitière c'est l'islam vous
dites on se fait traiter d'islamophobe
quand on critique le coran alors qu on
s'arroge le droit de bombarder les
musulmans en libye en syrie c'est très
juste ça c'est surtout sera un problème
c'est à dire que quand on dit ward
guarding sont barbares ils font des
choses effrayantes îles des canaries des
journalistes où ils ont cassé des ils
ont cassé des stats lg oui d'accord mais
enfin nous aussi on tue des enfants avec
les avions qui bombardent de
l'afghanistan avec des avions qui
bombardent le mali non c'est pas ce qui
se passera jamais d'image on voit jamais
d'image mais on imagine bien que quand
on détruit des villages et ont détruit
des femmes des enfants des musées le
mans qui n'ont rien fait je dis que si
on veut penser ces choses là avec un peu
d'altitude il faut voir qu'on a une
politique islamophobe sur la planète
entière et après tout pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va pas bombarder la chine le
pakistan oui nous cuba on voit bien
pourquoi
on va là récemment sur votre site et
repris la thèse du choc des
civilisations de samuel un petit tonnes
alors pour vous l'occident féminisé a
perdu la bataille contre un islam
belliciste en fait
je crois qu'il ya un islam qui est en
pleine forme aujourd'hui parce qu'une
civilisation et se construit avec des
spiritualités l'occident est en train de
s'effondrer il a il a vécu quand même
près de vingt siècles quand même déjà
beaucoup et on a en face une
civilisation de substitution c'est une
oumma c'est une communauté planétaire et
cette communauté planétaire elle est
prête pour devenir une civilisation
globale et laurent parlait on passe
maintenant au dossier de la semaine avec
les vitres de blacko et c'est
l'historien fabrice d'almeida que nous
accueillerons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto ce soir nous poserons la
question notre civilisation et l foutu
mais les messieurs
[Musique]
la civilisation occidentale se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans la même situation que
l'empiré romain moment de son déclin
l'époque de lempire fasa le monde de sa
richesse et son harnais paraissait
invincible les riches rouler dans la
voiture et le peuple se tenait
tranquille tant qu'on lui offrait du
pain et des jeux ça vous rappelle
quelque chose alors attendez la suite
tandis que les romains sont avachis dans
leur confort
une secte de barbus qui illumine et
débarque de palestine les chrétiens
faisons des fanatiques cherche à
convertir toute la société on les accuse
même d'avoir déclenché un incendie il ya
dévasté rome pendant six jours en
faisant des milliers de morts wingles et
cela leur nombre ne cesse d'augmenter
mais quand on les jette au lion il meurt
en criant le nom de leur dieu ce qui
déclenche de nouvelles vocations de
marty et là ça vous rappelle quelque
chose le plus inquiétant sion poursuit
parallèle c'est quand 313 l'empiré
romain est devenue un empire chrétiens
alors est-ce que les fièvres de l'islam
radical pourrait se propager de la même
manière en occident aujourd'hui l'europe
s'est détourné de ses racines
chrétiennes et en france la laïcité
considère le recul de la religion comme
un progrès sauf que sans religion une
société perd le sens du sacré truc est
sacrée c'est ce pour quoi on est prêt à
se sacrifier
en 1914 les français partaient à la
guerre fleur au fusil ils pourraient à
donner leur vie pour la patrie mais
aujourd'hui qui est prêt à mourir pour
la france déjà que sacrifier un peu de
son temps pour aller voter ça saoule la
majorité c'est le leur en demandait pas
plus les occidentaux c'est tellement
déprimé ils ne font même plus assez
d'enfants pour assurer le remplacement
des générations sans compter qu'en plus
du déclin démographique qui est le
déclin économique croissance en panne d
industrialisation déficit chronique des
budgets de l'état et pendant ce temps
les pays du golfe accumule les milliards
ce qui a permis au qatar de prendre des
parts dans lagardère veolia total et
vivendi ici pour éviter les ennuis les
français acceptait de se soumettre à
l'islam c'est ce qu'a imaginé michel
houellebecq dans son roman soumission
les françaises sont des fanatiques oui
mais du confort et des supermarchés
alors pour préserver cette petite vie
sans histoire sommes nous prêts à
renoncer aux valeurs qui font notre
civilisation
voilà c'était d'éviter de bientôt mise
en images de juniac grave
fabrice d'almeida bonsoir ni historien
professeur appareils 2 auteur de
nombreux livres et vous présentez
également sur france 5 la casse du
siècle
tous les dimanches à 22h25 bienvenue
parmi nous merci voilà la question de la
semaine et donc notre civilisation et l
foutu et je demande pas ça uniquement
parce que je suis tombé sur les anges de
la télé réalité sur nrj12
alors michel onfray votre prochain livre
s'appelle décadence et c'est vrai que
après la première guerre paul valéry
écrivez nous autres civilisations
nous savons désormais que nous sommes
mortels et eagle disait comme sur les
alignements de stonehenge les pyramides
du caire le parthénon d'athènes où les
ruines de rome on méditera plus tard sur
les ruines des cathédrales vous écrivez
notre occident et en décomposition et
c'est vrai dites vous la femme à barbe
conchita wurz constitue l'horizon
indépassable du progrès les animaux
domestiques
celle ci qu'analyste la marchandisation
de l'utérus des femmes pauvres pour
porter les foetus des riches c'est vrai
qu'en occident aujourd'hui personne
n'est prêt à mourir pendant le droit
d'acheter un nouvel iphone tous les cinq
ans
alors
décomposition oui je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord avec paul valéry mais
personne n'est capable de dire que ça
fonctionne aussi chez nous touche et
nous nous c'est à dire l'occident on a
l'impression que on est on est là pour
toujours et que c'est la pleine forme
c'est la pleine santé etc si on arrête
de penser dans l'instant pure et bien on
regarde d'un peu plus haut et on regarde
notre civilisation elle a une date de
naissance et là une croissance est là un
moment extraordinaire quand on prend une
carte du 12e siècle et et qu'on regarde
l'installation des abbayes cisterciennes
par exemple c'est constellé de l'abbaye
cistercienne est donc une grande santé
chrétienne à ce moment là et puis on
voit qu'avec la renaissance avec des
cartes etc enfin on l'a vu la puissance
de la raison devient de plus en plus
grande la raison la religion recule et
que il ya une espèce de lente descente
jusqu'à une disparition de cette
civilisation il faut comprendre que les
civilisations dans leur temps quinze
vingt siècles enfants dira quinze
siècles pour le christianisme c'est
beaucoup pour une civilisation
maintenant notre civilisation personne
n'est prêt à se battre et à mourir pour
elle
civilisation et dole food ou non je suis
embêté parce que je suis pas sûr qu'on
soit la civilisation chrétienne pour
tout dire et j'ai même l'impression
qu'on est très éloignée de ça en fait si
on se dit qu'en utilisation elle repose
par exemple sur la démocratie sur le
marché sur un aspect qui renvoie
beaucoup elle à l'un des maîtres de
michel onfray qui est prudent notre
civilisation repose beaucoup sur le
droit de propriété et si on raisonne
comme ça on se dit que ben il reste
peut-être des horizons lointains et
comme historiens c'est vrai quand on
cherche des critères objectifs pour dire
est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui en déclin
économiquement on reste quand même le
monde occidental très très très puissant
militairement
encore très très très très puissant
technologiquement je pense que là il ya
même un gap avec les autres
civilisations et les autres
civilisations région géographique qui
est à mon avis énorme donc je n'ai pas
la même lecture en revanche que les
civilisations soit mortel oui et elles
l'ont montré à plusieurs reprises la
jeune femme oui je crois pas que c'est
le christianisme pour qui nous définit
je pense même que ce qui nous
définissent et ça a été dit bien par un
michel onfray c'est effectivement les
certaine culture matérielle et
et pour ma part je ne m'en désole pas
c'est à dire qu en fait j'aime bien
notre mode de vie est la dernière chose
peut-être est-ce qu'on est prêt à mourir
pour ça et moi je dois avouer que à
chaque fois qu'on a cette discussion je
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à des amis
militaires je peux pas m'empêcher même
de penser à cette jeune femme aurélie
sallèles caporal chef des sapeurs
pompiers de paris qui la semaine
dernière est morte au feu donc je n'aime
pas beaucoup quand on dit voilà est-ce
qu'on est près un mois pour sa personne
n'est pas mon cas ça alors que en fait
on a à peu près 400 personnes qui sont
morts aussi en opérations extérieures ça
prouve bien qu'il ya des ressources de
sacrifice des ressources de don de soi
pour la collectivité c'est vrai qu'on
peut dire al'inverse le modèle
occidental s'impose partout sur la
planète finalement c'est même une menace
écologique on voit bien qu'un peu
partout dans le monde le mode de vie
alors on peut je sais pas comment on
peut la paix s'il faut l'appeler
occidental ou modernes ou post moderne
c'est-à-dire avec justement l'iphone
l'ordinateur portable et la volonté
d'être libre de son corps de ses
relations amoureuses etc on se rend
compte que c'est partout et c'est même
c'est là où c'est absolument fou c'est
même dans les pays musulmans on sert que
dans les pays musulmans et c'est tout
l'enjeu à mon avis aujourd'hui il ya des
gens qui veulent ce mode de vie là c'est
pour fait quand on est historien on a
l'impression que ce n'est pas seulement
un moment clé où tout s'arrête et qu'on
a l'impression qu'il ya déjà des mix il
ya des croisements il ya un croisement
entre le réac islamistes et la modernité
c'est à dire qu'il va utiliser le faux
téléphones portables ils ont du temps
ils ont déjà le trioxyde dallas bien
voilà et on a les mêmes circonstances et
nous une espèce de volonté est là je
fais exprès pour le titiller pour le
pousser une espèce de volonté de retour
à la terre de retour à la nature qui va
de pair avec la volonté de pouvoir
utiliser son ordinateur portable c'est
cette hybridation qui me paraît très
significative et qui me paraît moi être
aussi que c'est pas la décadence alors
ça c'est le capitalisme c'est le modèle
du capitalisme qui nous dit que la
vérité le bonheur dans le consumérisme
il ya plein de gens qui ne veulent pas
ça donc je ne crois pas que l'occident
soit en pleine forme parce que le
capitalisme est en forme le capitalisme
ils utilisent tous y compris l'islam
bien pour vous michel il ya bel et bien
un choc des civilisations
quoi qu'on dise effectivement les
intellectuels de gauche au nom du
politiquement correct alors est-ce qu'on
va se faire bouffer par les chinois ou
décapité par les arabes
vous fait pas les arabes a décapité par
les chiffres
il ya un truc comme dans votre dans
votre discours dans votre réflexion vous
dites entre l'islam et l'islamisme vous
vous faites l'amalgamé vous regrettez
d'ailleurs que au moment de charlie
hebdo tout le monde et d'ipad amalgame
pas d' amalgame alors je dis pas que
l'islam l'islamisme c'est la même chose
je refuse d'entendre des gens nous dire
que l'islamisme n'aurait rien à voir
avec nous dit c'est pas une question de
nature à 30 degrés voilà bah oui mais
c'est pas pareil c'est pas les biens
compris pas que c'est quand même chose
d'abord il faut pas blesser un tas de
gens pour qui le coran est l'occasion de
faire de la communauté de fabriquer de
la communauté et puis ceux pour lesquels
le coran est l'occasion de de faire des
actes mafieux criminelle et c'est
exactement la même chose que quand dans
le christianisme ont nagé celle qui nous
dit qu'il faut tendre tendre la joue
quand on prend un coup et puis un saint
paul qui nous dit qu'il faut décapiter
au nom du christianisme et c'est donc on
voit bien que c'est une théorie du
prélèvement n'y a pas de n'y a pas de
corans sang musulman il n'ya pas de
musulmans sans musulmans qui va prélever
dans le corps en matière à faire de la
paix ou matière à faire de la guerre
fabrice moi j'ai un petit peu de mal
avec le choc des civilisations ce qu'on
peut constater aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
ya des acteurs à l'échelle
internationale qui reste encore des
états qui construisent des empires qui
ont des vocations impérialistes il ya
des groupes non étatiques qui essaye de
prendre et de construire leur propre
espace donc je trouve que c'est plus
intéressant de le regarder comme ça
comme une espèce d'histoire avec des
gens qui essayent de se tailler leur
royaume d'autres de les bloquer et c'est
plutôt que de dire ben voila en gros ça
va être l'occident contre l'orient et ça
va se passer comme ça tu vois pas ce que
ça me paraît pas du tout adapté à la
compréhension en fait bien attention
dernière question est ce qu'un match psg
om peut être considéré comme un choc de
civilisations
[Rires]
bien public merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup voilà c'est tu n'as plus
juste et on se retrouve après la plus
avec le zapping gaspard proust et
notariat nous sommes dix acteurs ce soir
gilles et marcel bloch il est
polyhandicapé
des assistants sexuels qui sont tombés
amoureux
se sont mariés
[Musique]
bonsoir et tériade bonsoir l'été à la
motion de retour sur terre toujours en
compagnie de josiane balasko
de l'ago de feu
de michel onfray
et 2 ennuis
[Applaudissements]
et nous accueillons nos terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir jean et marcel
mu bonsoir
alors
dit il
après avoir connu le monde de libertin
et avoir été escort-girl vous êtes
devenu accompagnantes sexuels pour
personnes handicapées vous marcel
atteint d'une maladie génétique à vous
avez passé toute votre vie sur un
fauteuil et un jour vos chemins se sont
croisés vous êtes tombé follement
amoureux l'un de l'autre et vous vous
êtes mariés voilà vous nous raconterez
votre histoire à 20h dans un instant
gaspard proust mais d'abord le zapping
c'était le zapping et maintenant
j'accueille gaspard proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
tunisie à vous savez comment ils ont
lancé la saison touristique en tunisie
1-1 quoi il ça plus quoi inventer pour
dire aux européens que cette année sera
moins cher d'aller à djerba qu'à paris
plages c'est alors ok les mecs qui font
jihad ils sont ils sont bourrés de
défauts et casse les gens ils cassent
les statuts mais savent aussi de casser
les prix d'un séjour ça c'est quelque
chose il faut respecter ça mais il faut
quand même essayer de sortir quelque
chose de positif de ce qui se passe
parce que les djihadistes après les
boudins en afghanistan le musée de
bruxelles le musée de tunis tu sens que
la culture c'est quand même un truc qui
les interpellent
ils ont pas forcément les codes mais ça
les interpelle
tu sens qu'ils ont besoin de se
raccrocher un truc même quand ils
entrent dans un musée il n'arrive pas
encore à y aller sans kalach ils ont tué
sans que la kalachnikov pour eux c'est
pas une arme c'est un doudou c'est
l'ism le coran ça on peut pas leur
enlever la récitation c'est leur truc
c'est quand même mal foutu l'avenir les
mets qu'ils adorent apprendre par coeur
le seul truc pour lequel n'y a pas
d'examen au bac
malheureusement toutes façons qui se
passe des choses parce que moi je dois
avouer que j'ai pas trop suivi j'étais
au canada là j'ai fait de l'héliski
pendant une semaine et je prenais
l'hélico douze fois par jour non mais
ses auteurs est douze fois par jour et
je suis toujours là
comme quoi ce type de voyage c'est
toujours un peu plus sur caen c'est toi
qui tu le payes que quand c'est tf1 qui
te l'offre
[Applaudissements]
ea mais y'a pas à chier délit côté
magique ça c'était magique tu survol des
montagnes des forêts étaient suspendus
au ciel dans une tondeuse en symbiose
totale avec la mélodie du rotor l'odeur
du kérosène en dessous tu vois les ours
les élans qui courent c'est forcément
grandis [ __ ] si j'avais un fusil
il ya l'été part de mental je crois en
ce moment et on ça j'ai pas le droit d'y
on n'a pas le droit de parler de ces
cons parce que c'est vraiment des
élections passionnante
bon ça me passionne
sélection que je préfère
et moi je ne peux pas parler de
politique après si je peux si alors mais
si je parle du fn je te suis parler du
ps et de l'ump et des verts et du front
de gauche au fond l'égalité pour tous et
ce truc qui donne vraiment envie de
parler de personnes
obèses malheur vous avez un nouveau
cancer qui est provoquée par des
implants mammaires et là d'un coup je me
suis dit mais pour la première fois de
ma vie mais ça m'a fait réfléchir quoi
mais mesdames pourquoi ou fait refaire
les seins alors que nous on vous aime
comme vous êtes
non pas en ce moment je bosse à rôles au
cinéma il faut être très premier degré
j'essaye encore une fois je
mais pourquoi les femmes se font refaire
les seins est ce que l'essentiel c'est
pas de s'accepter comme on est
alors je recommence plouf plouf on ne
voit bien qu'avec le coeur
j'arrive pas non je l'aurais jamais
c'est pas grave non mais plus
sérieusement une femme avec des seins
refaits ça n'a aucun intérêt je veux
dire nous autres humoristes on préfère
le vrai aux fautes face aux vendeurs
michel onfray l'a très bien dit dans un
de ces bouquins je crois ce bien avant
10h c'était par delà le sang sur le mal
il a dit je préfère avoir raison avec
jane birkin qu'avoir tort avec nabila
non mais
on peut oublier le bistouri mesdames
vous êtes belle comme vous êtes croyant
plus moi je suis adepte des femmes mûres
il ya un côté et un côté ludique c'est
quand tu soulèves lesaint tu sais jamais
si tu vas tomber sur les genoux le
nombril
ibrahimovic donc cela thann a traité la
france deux pays de merde il est
impressionnant ce n'est qu'un ça fait à
peine un an et demi qu'il est en france
et non seulement il a compris les
réalités du pays mais en plus il a moins
d'accent cris berry
france inter mathieu gallet pdg de radio
france a fait rénover son bureau pour
cent mille euros ouais c'est autant
maîtres du cuir croco dans une twingo
c'est vraiment
une affaire qui rappelle l'appartement
du patron de la cgt mais il faut se dire
mathieu gallet il est comme thierry le
paon il a besoin de décompresser après
tout lui aussi il dirigeait un syndicat
de grévistes
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle de la semaine heures cia
il m'est arrivé un truc que je voulais
partager avec la population
je saute le pas je m'installe en couple
oui ouais je viens d'acheter un appart
en viager
on passe maintenant à noter rien du
samedi 20 heures
alors gilles et marcel nuss rebond soir
jill commençons par vous vous êtes né le
24 octobre 1984 a pointé alto dans la
banlieue sud de santiago du chili à
l'âge de trois mois vous êtes adopté par
un couple de parisiens père ingénieur
mère directrice du marketing dans un
groupe international vous grandissez à
rueil malmaison dans un confort matériel
et affectif total wima adopté désirer
les démarches d'adoption sont très
longues donc forcément la petite
princesse qui manquent de rien voilà
mais à l'adolescence vous vous sentez
pas très à l'aise dans votre tête et
dans votre milieu social vous refusez la
vie rangée qui vous attend à 14 ans vous
abandonnez l'école pour un cap2
mécanique oui je suis parti de chez mes
parents à 15 ans est donc là vous partez
pour suivre une bande de jaunards
une vie de bohème ce qu'on appelle une
vie de bohème j'ai vécu dans la rue j'ai
connu le monde de la nuit
j'ai fait mes propres expériences
marcel vous êtes né le 13 février
1955 a jailli ce pôle shy'm dresse plus
hype près de strasbourg père menuisier
mère femme au foyer
et à huit mois une forte fièvre vous
cloue au lit
huit mois d'hospitalisation plus tard la
médecine se déclare impuissante sur
votre cas on parle de poliomyélite de
myopathie en fait vous êtes atteint
d'amyotrophie spinale
une maladie congénitale évolutive vous
êtes bien renseigné à partir de 5 ans
c'est le fauteuil oui à 9 ans vous êtes
incapable de vous asseoir sans corset
mais vous êtes scolarisés dans l'école
du village je pense que ça va beaucoup
et dif 1 oui ça m'a permis de mûrir
d'affronter la vraie vie à 15 ans
malheureusement vous êtes trop faible
pour aller à l'école
et entre 16 et 17 ans vous perdez
l'usagé de vos membres supérieurs à 19
en arrêt respiratoire
ou partez à l'hôpital pour huit jours
huit jours de coma vous y resterez six
ans
ça c'est en fait le vrai début de la vie
ouais c'est très paradoxal
il a fallu que je
que je frôle la mort
pour aller vraiment envie
alors gilles à l'adolescence vous
découvrez c'est normal votre sexualité
découvrir vous êtes bisexuelle
mais c'est avec des garçons que vous
vivrez deux grandes histoires d'amour 5
ans et 6 et pendant ces deux histoires
vous avez été extrêmement fidèle à ses
garçons toujours
mais après chacune de ces expériences
vous profitez de votre célibat et vous
découvrez le monde libertin vous dites
je me suis beaucoup amusé faire l'amour
avec des inconnus j'ai un truc qui vous
plaisent et oui oui tout à fait j'ai
vu que j'avais aucun a priori à coucher
avec soit des hommes soient des femmes
des inconnus c'est là que vous décidez
d'en faire votre métier et vous devenez
escorte girl
marcel vous vous découvrez la sexualité
à travers les confidences des
infirmières parfois c'est hyper chose
qu'elle pourra conseil perchaud mais si
vous êtes le confident de ces dames
malheureusement quand vous voulez leur
raconter vos vos histoires elle refuse
de vous écouter en général elles partent
en courant et oui alors le jour une
infirmière découvre que vous demandez
elle quitte la chambre est la honte de
ce à quoi oui en fait
à l'époque j'étais tellement mal
que j'ai fait exprès de bondy de oued
alors oui d'accord a pris montré que
j'étais dans mon mari
et puis un jour à l'hôpital vous
rencontrez une jeune infirmière de 21
ans gaby
une amitié se noue et bientôt vous
découvrez que c'est de l'amour contre
l'avis général cette gaby va vous
installer chez elle elle démissionne de
l'hôpital pour s'occuper de vous 24
heures sur 24 formidable c'est une
aventure
amoureuse et humaine
alors avec gaby vous faites l'amour
vous mariez
vous faites deux enfants et we kiss en
très bonne santé elles vont très bien
suivront très bien alors dit là ce
moment là vous êtes escort girls pour le
fun dites vous et un jour un homme vous
appelle pour s'offrir vos services il
vous avoue qu'il est tétraplégique
cloué sur un fauteuil et vous répondez
oui alors on a tous nos problèmes je
suis exactement et là au lieu d'y passer
une heure 1 vous y passer l'après midi
cet homme va devenir un client régulier
et vous permettre de découvrir une chose
très importante vous trouvez à votre vie
une utilité sociale oui à ce moment là
j'ai donc lu cette prise de conscience
et je sentais effectivement que dans ces
rencontres
il se jouait vraiment autre chose ouais
je sentais que j'apportais quelque chose
aux clients valide mais l'aja portait
beaucoup plus également beaucoup plus et
vous devenez assistantes sexuelles vous
dites la prostitution classique c'est
pour le fun
l'assistance sexuelle c'est pour la
cause
alors c'est vrai mais par exemple la
scène d'intouchable ou françois accusés
se fait masser les oreilles par une
prostituée est vrai c'est que le désir
des places les zones érogènes évidemment
oui or marcel en 2001 après 20 ans de
vie commune vous vous séparez de gaby
sauf que avec 900 euros par mois vous ne
pouvez payer que trois heures par jour
d'accompagnement c'est ça alors là pour
éviter l' institution spécialisée les
deux formidables vous remuer ciel et
terre et grâce à votre combat la loi
change vous obtenez les moyens d'engager
des personnes pour s'occuper de vous 24
sur 24 vous allez voir ségolène royal
quoi je lui ai fait
deux grèves de la faim n'a pas apprécié
et en plus j'ai médiatisé
le sait-elle ou rigide
d'une vraie révolution sociale c'est ça
qui sera en finale
et d'égaliser en 2005 voilà
là dessus vous écrivez votre biographie
vous écrivez des essais vous écrivez de
la poésie et surtout vous commencez
marcel à parcourir la france pour donner
des conférences consacrées aux
handicapés à leurs problèmes à commencer
par le sexe jeux seront la souffrance
de ces personnes handicapées
sont dans la solitude qui sont
magnan d'institutions
n'est pas en vain
et
de leur apporter un peu du bien je pars
du principe que j'ai des capacités
de lisier
donc ciamada les
sabres est d'ouvrir les portes
voilà alors devenu une référence dans le
domaine et ses activités dont vous amène
à rencontrer des fans marion je suis dit
lily enfin on peut dire d un tombeur
marcel ce que je trouve très drôle
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on me demande comment je fonce
alors qu'il ya 30 ans
et est rare handicapés deal à la même
époque
le sexe chez les handicapés devient pour
vous une raison d'être vous lisez les
bouquins de marcel
vous regardez les vidéos de marcel sur
youtube
johnny une groupie oui j'étais fan de
marcel et j'espère un jour pouvoir le
rencontrer ouais
et marcel donc un jour un ami sexologue
vous recommande gilles pour un handicapé
en détresse et c'est comme ça que vous
vous rencontrer tous les deux au début
vous discuté sur skype et un jour vous
dites j'en ai ras-le-bol du virtuel et
vous invitez jill pour un week-end en
alsace et depuis vous n'êtes jamais
quittée en fait
je suis allé j'ai fait 600 km pour aller
rencontrer marcel et quand on s'est vus
voilà on a commencé à discuter au bout
d'une heure il m'a dit la chambre d'amis
est prête j'ai dit est ce que je peux
dormir avec toi ce soir qu'est ce qui
vous a plu chez lui son charisme oui son
charisme son humour
ses poèmes aussi parce que ce sont des
poèmes érotiques en général forcément ce
qu'il faut dire aussi parce qu'on
pourrait dire elle fait ça pour le
pognon c'est qu'en fait il a très peu
d'argent il a quoi 900 euros par mois
oui l'allocation adulte handicapé ouais
c'est juste que vous l'aimez quoi c'est
juste ça c'est simple
vous êtes mariés on s'est marié 14
février dernier oui mais renvoie dans
son bateau des prochains [ __ ]
apporterait alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est une salle unique à rien
votre coque du samedi soir avec jean
louis
josiane balasko
lago de feu michel onfray thil et marcel
nuss merci beaucoup fabrice d'almeida
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission salut mais ça
coupez les corps est sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
mettait un peu ce bleu